okay we're in route to one of the few
remaining blockbusters in the world I'm
not exactly sure I'm an Air Left
currently but we are driving to Indiana
oh my god
oh god it's blockbuster yeah it's a
blockbuster they exist they're real
that's crazy oh my gosh I feel like I'm
in 1999 get ready for the fields guys
this video was so much fun to make and
incredibly nostalgic I haven't had this
much fun making a retro rewind since I
made my Toonami retro rewind and I got
to talk with Christopher Sabbath the
voice of Vegeta and Steve Blum the voice
of Tom and Spike Spiegel making this
retro rewind was very special my wife
and I actually drove out of state to
Indiana to one of the few remaining
blockbusters that are still in existence
we thought they were all gone but there
are still a handful of people who have
been able to hold on to their franchises
and we walked around in an actual
blockbuster and oh my gosh it was insane
oh my god I'm gonna cry I am going to
cry look at this holy this is an
actual blockbuster that exists on earth
I currently have no words to express how
I feel at this time
I am walking through a blockbuster this
is crazy oh my god I am walking through
a blockbuster you guys I don't know what
to say right now I have no idea what to
say this is insane you know I think it
was cool with the owner I'm just gonna
sleep here tonight
because I feel like I'm at home
walking in this store was so nostalgic
for me because I remember a time where I
used to be able to go to a rental store
pick up a VHS or a DVD examine it see
two thumbs up by Siskel and Ebert or
some other critic quote and decide I
want to watch this because I'm holding
it in my hand and this looks really cool
seeing all different types of video game
cover art that I was enticed by video
games I wanted to play movies I wanted
to rent things I wanted to experience
going to Blockbuster with your friends
on a Friday night was a huge thing
people hung out there all the time I
used to hang out had blockbusters with
my friends it was like a thing we would
all find some movie we wanted to watch
or make fun of or laugh at eat candy
with popcorn pizza and just have a great
time or rent a video game and just play
it all night that was a big thing on
weekends in the late 90s nowadays with
things like Netflix movie rental stores
are considerably fewer now I'm not
bashing Netflix I have an account myself
and I like it very much Netflix is a
fantastic idea and a great invention but
there is something special about a movie
/ video game rental store there's
nothing like it there's nothing like
going to one of these places another big
one for my friends and I back in the day
was Hollywood video do you guys remember
Hollywood video my wife and I actually
tracked down a nearby Hollywood video
that still has all of its signs up the
game crazy side of the store where you
could pick out an older or a newer video
game it was really crazy to stand there
and remember the fact that I used to go
to places like this my hollywood video
had pictures of Jim Carrey as the mask
and Batman Forever 's Val Kilmer seeing
that store there barren with nobody
going to it nobody renting from it it
brought a little tear to my eye because
I vividly remember going to places like
that and the blockbuster that my wife
went to when she was a kid still has one
small remnant left behind from the past
and we filmed it
is my old blockbuster location obviously
out of business but this is the last
remaining little artifact of the
blockbuster here is the quick Dropbox I
talked with my dad a lot for not
returning the movies
the ladies surprisingly there are a lot
of people out there that think rental
stores are completely gone that Netflix
and streaming has completely crushed the
market but that's actually not true
there are still a lot one of the biggest
ones on the East Coast is family video
and we filmed in front of one guy's
family video is one of the last
remaining video rental chains on the
East Coast in fact it's not very well
known anywhere else but there's tons of
them in Ohio it's basically like
blockbuster except they sell adult films
even though they're called family video
which is weird let's go inside family
video is actually pretty big where I
lived there's a lot in Ohio there's some
in Indiana and I believe on the east
coast mainly family videos are fairly
successful still a ton of people enjoy
going to rental stores and to be honest
a lot of video games that I have
reviewed in the past I've actually been
able to rent at family video for like
six bucks have the game for a week and I
was able to beat it and review it for
you guys rather than paying $60 to buy a
new game that I don't necessarily want
some of the games I've reviewed I have
bought but family video thanks to them a
lot of the reviews I've done for video
games I only spent like six dollars on
the game to rent and that's kind of
awesome this one has a Marko's of pizza
inside the finger video so you can shop
and rent movies and stuff while you
order pizza and wait for it it's
incredible
Ohio it's pretty awesome guys despite
what you might think we do have some
cool stuff you can rent any kids movie
there for free they're always doing
these charity drives it's really awesome
I love the fact that there's still a
rental place on the east coast that I
can enjoy and growing up I went to this
place called discount drug Mart it's
this store in Ohio that actually still
does rent movies even today I have no
idea how successful that side of their
business is but my wife and I went in
there today and found a ton of new
releases and a whole bunch of stuff
that's still for rent so like I said I
love Netflix I have an Amazon Prime
account I like all that stuff too
but there is something special there's a
novelty in going to one of these places
walking inside smelling all of the DVDs
and in the 90s the VHS is knowing that
there's this world in front of you where
you can pick up things and hold them and
look at them and it wasn't just the idea
being at a rental store it was a
legitimate thing to do with your friends
and I spent hours upon hours inside
blockbusters in Hollywood videos thanks
to Hollywood video I discovered a ton of
anime that I would have never
experienced back in the day because they
had a fairly massive anime VHS rental
section for only 99 cents you could rent
just about any anime at Hollywood video
which was nuts for me but they were
always like well people don't like anime
as much so we'll make it cheaper but I
was like oh I like anime and I want to
rent like seven of these right now and
watch all of them so it was really cool
and before you could look up any video
game code or cheat or walkthrough on the
Internet I got blockbusters secret code
guides which I have like from 97 to 2001
I think
saved because it's awesome its
blockbuster guys what I'd like to know
is do you have a special memory or
something associated with a video rental
store let me know in the comments below
share your story with everybody I would
like to hear it I'd like to read it you
guys are the best thank you so much for
watching this special episode of retro
rewind we went out of our way to make
this one better because as soon as I
found out there was actually still a
blockbuster nearby I was like I must go
there we must film in it I have to do it
and I hope you guys appreciated that if
you liked this video share it around
maybe we can get some more discussion
talking about the fact that video rental
stores are still pretty cool I mean
obviously we're going to have Netflix
forever but there's a special thing
about these that nothing else can really
duplicate guys thank you so much as
always for watching and if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
you